this week on quadriga pegida goes europe
fear is the key
the patriotic europeans against the
islamization of the west have found
supporters outside germany Paquita
denmark has already conducted a march in
austria a chapter is also planning a
similar demonstration in february on
facebook the movement has now also found
adherents in countries from sweden to
spain polls indicate that around 3 & 4
germans rejects the approach will it go
the way of other short-lived protest
movements or could pegida
grow into a europe-wide phenomenon your
host this week peter craven well hello
and a very warm welcome to this latest
edition of quadriga coming to you from
berlin where we're discussing this
extraordinary phenomenon pegida that has
been at the top of the international
news agenda the domestic agenda here in
germany for several weeks now what's it
all about how concerned should we be
what is the European dimension of it all
to discuss these very important
questions I'm joined here in the studio
by three keen observers I'd like to
introduce them to you without any
further ado beginning with Johanna
slight hyzer who is from the Frankfurter
Allgemeine a newspaper where he has been
London correspondent and he currently
focuses on German domestic and
international policy also the writer and
commentator Schaffer Shanna Jack who
lives here in Germany here in Berlin and
in fact has for a long time indeed he
was though born in Turkey he's a
specialist I think it's fair to say on
the poetry and the politics of living in
two different worlds he's nodding at
least about that yeah and last but not
least Judy Dempsey currently a writer
and analyst for the Carnegie Foundation
Judy has worked for a host of
international broadcasters in a long and
illustrious career and Judy I would like
to begin with you
pegida pegida Peggy Rose you know
everybody's talking about pegida here in
Germany I know that you have given a lot
of thought to what pegida is all about
what sort of initial conclusions have
you come to
I think the most interesting conclusion
is what is is doing to German society
and it's as a kind of the very existence
of pegida which is clearly against Islam
more than sort of foreigners come from
EU countries Islamization it has woken
up the Germans and I've been very
impressed and relieved to see a swelling
of civil society and movement saying
no foreigners are welcome in this
country it's not a question of meeting
them we want to be an open country so I
think you know forgive you may have
taken more on them than they have
reckoned I think in the beginning they
expected a groundswell an enormous
support and being able to embarrass the
government and the political parties but
the other aspect of German society has
woken up mm-hmm pegida has woken up
German society talk what would you say I
think open discussions are part of open
society and it's always good to have
them I don't think this is a new
phenomenon what we see now is that
people are on the street this is new and
but the sentiment and the feeling this
fear of changing the society and
direction of more multicultural
conditions these people from very
different backgrounds living together
with schools with children different
backgrounds cultural tension also this
is nothing new and you have these
discussions in Germany since the 90s and
I would say discussion about double
citizenship all those issues going on
since 20 years and also this fight it
was a real a fight is Germany a country
of migration or not
if you remember mr. Kaul the Chancellor
was always saying Germany is not kind in
mando's lands not and country of
immigration
so Germans have to adjust to this new
situation and I think in the West they
are already in vast majority adjusted to
it and we are working on it all together
migrants and the old population of the
country and this coalition of the
newcomers and the old ones and the old
ones there is also first the second
generation of migrants we are forgetting
this we are talking now about the
refugees and so on
they also pegida for example this is a
big subject people who will come in the
next years and now the refugees who who
can come who is not allowed to enter and
so on but my god this country had around
15 to 20 million people entering the
country since the 1960's guest workers
and so on and I think it is in fact a
positive experience for Germany and the
level of integration is very high if you
compare it with some other European
countries but we have a problem we have
a PR problem we have real a peer problem
because we have of course there are
problems migration is no very easy and
people are different and we have a very
very difficult past in Germany with
sadness so we have to discuss all those
issues together
I agree but we have a little bit to show
the modern open society of Germany we
can be proud of this I will say and in
outside people look on Germany like this
you know we will look this is an current
force with a strong country with a
democratic society open society which is
welcoming people and integrating them
faster than others do but there are
elements of the international press who
have been suggesting that the walk
pegida amounts to is the beginnings of a
resurgence of far right-wing sentiment
in germany as a right to suggest that in
general that's not yes because we have
this movements already in France in
Austria and
Denmark very strong and in Germany was a
little bit exception I would say because
of the past this is all this national
issues you know borders national
identity those are all issues in Germany
was a special tune and I think it's it's
the last step of an European movement of
identity yeah I mean you could take
things easy and can say could say yeah
that that's just now a phenomenon that
shows Germany is going to normalize it's
the last taboo broken after this long
post-war period we were living in but I
think he would even honor these pegida
organizers at least too much if you
would give them the same rank that for
national has in France for instance or
you cap has got in Great Britain or
other these are journalists and I'm sure
it's a problem that we all have actually
describing pinkey are actually trying to
quantify pegida because I very often as
a sort of a journalistic shorthand I do
and I did I noticed I did at the
beginning of the show and I promised
myself I wasn't going to I called them a
movement and my right to do so is pegida
a movement or is it a ragbag of people
who are disgruntled and and disillusion
say I think it's rather the latter than
the first the organisers not even the
organizers I would say have a clear idea
of what they want with it they like the
power of standing on a market place and
having 10,000 people assembled around
them if you're going to ask the people
there I think they have a wide range of
issues and even even though they are
calling themselves Europeans against I
would doubt that a majority of them is
even European minded it's fascinating
isn't it that they have chosen to call
themselves Europeans yeah rather than
Germans in the first instance
understandably because I think they want
to say they don't want to although many
although the patriotic element is there
in the name itself by saying you if I
transfer
to the european language it's it's as if
to say it's not it's not unique to
germany we've got we've got we've got
organisations or support all over europe
so just don't put us on germany we this
is this is something much bigger and
it's european-wide
i think they try to borrow from this
more successful movements if you want in
other European countries by doing this
yes like from this you know like you
there's something particularly different
I mean there is a ragbag or not much
interesting is I'm not quite sure what
the policies are really apart from the
slogans but unlike you Kip and unlike
the conventional it's that the whole
euro scepticism hasn't come in yet which
is very different that that belongs for
the moment in the aft the alternative
for George London City seemed probably
hiding behind it and the aft this
alternative for Georgians you're a
skeptic in very you're a skeptic in fact
and indeed they would like Germany to be
taken out of the euro but this is
there's a strand inside that party who
certainly identifies with part of the
the nationalist elements in in pegida
and so sooner or later you know that
yeah the AFT will have to stand up and
say where it stands on this but do you
know I mean this your skepticism this is
an interesting question I I think until
now it's absolutely not clear if this
European Union will be something like
the United States of Europe in future or
it will be a kind of unification of
nation states of Europe you know it's
not clear and this is I think what
people makes nervous because as I can
observe in many European countries
people want to stay in this nation
states more or less we want to stay in
this nation says but wait won't they are
not against Europe we are not against
cooperation between the nations we are
not again but but the idea of this
United States of Europe
this came somehow to a kind of crisis
and we don't discuss it openly this adds
to this I think the common feeling of
the people assembled in Raceland alpha
is there's too much
on far above our heads where we have no
influence on and this is this is it is
and then this feeling you can then adapt
to all kinds of issues interior minister
Thomas de Moz yeah he came out and he
said he's been very level-headed in
recent times looking at in his dealings
with the big eater crisis he said these
people have are asking some very
important questions they have some
genuine grievances that need to be
addressed what are the genuine
grievances do you imagine that need to
be addressed I would I would say they
might have genuine feelings that it
wouldn't even go so far to say there
there's really problems that they are
bothered with and give them the right to
so what are the emotions is exactly
things are happening and we are not
involved in it we can't take back our my
I don't feel at home in this society or
in this in my surroundings in my
neighborhood anymore and this is their
it this is related to this special
geographic center where this takes place
East Germany
they have many of these people are on
this this marketplaces are well almost
only on the brink of retirement are more
older people than younger people they
have lost a country 25 years ago
East Germany dear they are many of them
were quite well adapted in this country
and liked it in in to a certain extent
and they had difficulties to to find
their way in the reunited bigger Germany
so this still is a burden they are
carrying on their back and now there's a
genuine sense of dislocation exactly
young mmm-hmm it's what the sociologists
I guess would say do do you mean isn't
it something isn't it something else as
well your highness
and it perhaps the mainstream parties
the post for mainstream parties across
Europe have run their course but they
haven't adapted to to sort of the post
modernization of Europe to globalization
and to adapting the policies and the
politics
to to the society to the citizens and
even those who aren't supportive of
pegida there's been discussions for a
long time particularly in Germany on the
the dislocation are the disaffection or
the disenchantment the crest of
alienation between the the state
political parties and the society and
you have lots of fringe movements lots
of little grassroots movements coming up
against airports and so on but somehow
this is tapping into a much broader and
tougher issue the role of the political
parties and the responsibility to the
just tell me a little bit more about
that alienation because I think a lot of
people will be looking at Germany
specifically at Germany they they'll
look to France for example and they will
see the bond year they'll see the social
problems in France we have social
problems in Germany too but most foreign
visitors when they come to job I mean
people are flocking to Germany to live
here yeah and most people when they look
to Germany when they come to Germany
they say to me I would actually quite
like to live like this this seems like a
well-run well-organized society with a
high level of employment and a high high
broadly high levels of prosperity so why
are so many people alienated their
alienation because politics has become
detached and so alienation because
politicians are generally speaking have
to have taken have taken for granted
that the elections will come around and
you will go and vote on the voter
turnout is getting lower and lower
much much - and that's quite a sadder
dangerous thing and there's a feeling
that the even on the lower level of
councilors local councils that the
relationship between young people
particularly isn't there anymore let me
give you an example and small in
Germany's neighbor in Poland for the
election turnout is just plummeting now
which is which is quite frightening
given that it's only had what freedom
for 25 years what has happened in in
Poznan for instance which is not so far
from Germany industrial city thriving
young people have taken it into the
whole own hands to organise the parks to
have designed to have competitions how
the roads should be done for the
infrastructure for schools because they
don't feel the local councillors are
listening and I think now with the
bureaus
socrates ation of politics perhaps and
globalization that the feeling of
identity between the the politician and
the citizen is widening
so pegida could actually signal a sort
of accrete occur people actually saying
we want more participation in society
this is very old and very normal problem
for all democratic societies I would say
if there are elected people there's
always a distance between people and
people on the ground I think that the
source is coming from somewhere else
it's not about politics it's about
changing the environment you know you
had in the the last 50 years and big
parts of western Germany the results of
immigration you can see it's very very
well and the big part of belly and you
can see it in a city like calm but those
in cities like Homburg Dortmund isn't of
big German cities we change anonymously
and I will say that a majority of
Germans appreciate that let's say we
became an open society became more
international also the guys coming to
Germany and say oh I want to live here
for example or I have a lot of friends
in the United States I say
I want to live in boolean this is the
best city for me this is a part of this
fiction of of this multicultural open
society and its functions not that bad I
must say but that it functions in the
fantasy of people in Dresden it Shireen
in Rostock this is the question is that
also are in eastern Germany Slee in
eastern Germany you know some parts of
West but I well the area is
underestimated a lot yes underestimate a
lot if you go to the city like number
and so on even Munich there are not a
lot of anti protest is going on -
against Paquita I think the big question
the challenge is to say maybe to these
people listen not everywhere things have
to change I mean if you won't read
because it's a kind of parallel society
we were always talking about parents
societies of the migrants
but there is also a parent society of
people who are all citizens of this
country and this parallel society says
we don't want neighbors who have another
color
we don't want neighbors they have
another religion there are people like
this and so they live together and they
they have a community which is very
different from the mixed parts of the
country I think one of the reasons for
this is we are living together in the
German society somewhat closer or more
equalized than in any other Western
European society let alone countries
outside of you it's a more egalitarian
society I'd say that's one of the
results of the second world war and of
Nazi times we don't have any aristocracy
left that was so much discredited
because of dealing with Hitler we don't
have many a beauty and I are looking at
each other I'm wondering if we should
leap in and question well you can Lee
mentioned my spell in the United Kingdom
and when I was living there I just came
to my mind I hadn't explained it before
thought about this how whatever what is
still what a class Society this is this
country is and that's gone in Germany
and this this result of this leads to
the feeling of many Germans that they
are observing the whole country the
whole society when things are changing
so there is no there's less tolerance
and less negligence in the German
society and that makes integration more
of a problem than in other countries
where just you have huge Arab population
in the Baniya of Paris with very
explosive results but people didn't care
for a long time or not politics at least
didn't and the majority did not address
this problem when you talk about a
cities like that when you talk about
those kind of phenomena we can go you
can go all the way around Europe you can
go to Amsterdam you go to Antwerp you
can go to Stockholm awesome Marseille
you can go to Frankfurt cities all
across Europe they have changed
incredibly within two generations
they've all got populations of 20% plus
who have migrant backgrounds yet
is that just the way of the world is
that the way things are inevitably going
to develop and and and the people who
like the beginner people but many others
who are saying I'm troubled about my own
sense of identity and trouble about my
own sense of homeland the German word hi
Matt comes up a lot is that something
that we just sort of sweep aside sweep
under the carpet or do we need to talk
about that
talk about it you know in the next 20 30
years around eight eight and a half
million people you have to come to
Germany as migrants if you want to keep
the level we have this Germany is a
chronically aging society it needs young
migrants yeah I I think there's an
element of wish-fulfilling here when it
comes to the migrants even the third
generation of Turks who came or who live
here now and and also recently there's
been a passivity well they're here we
don't have the huge high-rise suburbs
yeah they're integrated yes and then
when something happens like the trucks
that were killed in this racist attack
by this far right-wing movement down in
southern eastern Germany in Germany
again suddenly something clicked with
the two Germans I think more than pegida
gosh you know the the some of the police
officers and investigators and said oh
this is honor killings or something no
it was racism the establishment cause
it's serious and what I want to say is
that the misters sort of taken for
granted possibility all can all work out
but things don't work out integration is
a two-way process and I think over the
past couple of years and there's been
finally a big push to get em very very
young children three years old going
into the schools that the kindergartens
enjoy learning being able to have their
mother tongue of course but Germany
geordie have to learn German and this is
the first thing but much more
fundamental and this hasn't changed it's
the police and security forces they had
they have been largely dominated by
German Germans and for trust in the
community and given the other face of
the German society because there is
another face lead that the the civil
service this
security forces police particularly
judiciary they have to be opened up to
the true - migrants who are now living
here forever they come from this is
going to take time slowly there's a
discussion taking place about this okay
before we move on we've got we've got to
learn a short-film well we've got a cup
I think three or four voices from
contemporary Germany talking about where
we are at this point in time let's just
get a flavour of what they've got to say
Germany is not a country of immigration
integration doesn't mean just living
next door to one another but with one
another based on the common foundation
of the values set down in our
Constitution and our German cultural
identity which has been influenced by
its judeo-christian roots Christianity
humanism and the Enlightenment we're
afraid that one day the Germans in
Germany might become a minority it's not
just about foreigners it's about the
future about the general problem we
don't want to be walking around veiled
in 50 years time we don't want to be
Islamized it's let me see a thousand
Luther
when people are trying not to go out on
Mondays after 3:00 p.m.
the Muslims here avoid the streets I
often think and I'm often worried that
pipe will have a wall in their hearts
not like the Berlin wall this time
dividing east and west but a wall
dividing one Street from the next a wall
in their hearts suffer people are trying
not to go out on Mondays how worrying is
sit to hear that kind of comment because
we're talking in very liberal terms
about the progress that has been made in
recent decades in Germany but people are
not going out on the streets on a Monday
evening it's clear that they have a big
problem with this but you know
I think the key the key word here is in
fact Islam we have to talk about it
because it became a kind of symbol for
the other color in fact it's an issue of
color now it's not about religion it's
an issue color and second there are of
course big problems in Islamic societies
I mean it's obvious and it's coming over
the television I can I can understand
everyone who says oh my god what kind of
people are those I mean you know this
violence in the name of Islam in name of
God name of quran' and and muslims are a
little to take care of this issue and
stop it somehow we have to together
really together to have not talking only
about Islamophobia i mean there is of
course Islamophobia various also
anti-semitism it will be ever there will
never disappear i'm in this very
pessimistic it'll stay there but we have
we need our strategies against it we
have to show that how people can because
of course the problem of these people i
think there are a lot of people of among
this pegida demonstration so just are
really afraid but but they don't reflect
this that this community of of so-called
muslims people from muslim societies
there are so heterogeneous and there are
so many people who are secular we are
not believers who are allah weeds were
this her dad so the the small minority
of radicals somehow captured all of us
and we are now prisoners of this violent
and barbaric moment and we have to we
have to try really to find a new
coalition of of spirit normal people you
know what who wants to live in peace who
don't want have war in their hearts like
this lady said so this is the the very
very important message and what you're
describing to a certain extent is is a
polarization that there's a middle
ground but there's also there there are
radical fringes yeah but not the radical
fringes are in this radical islam that's
growing up in the middle
it's more that that's really clearly a
sign for our to put it the other way
around I think there's only one thing
Peggy diem maybe is right in saying
there's some issues are not discussed in
this society and one of these issues is
integration and what it needs to be
integrated and there have been
experiences now in in post-war Germany
over many decades in in the West we had
in the 60s many people coming from
southern Europe from Yugoslavia as it
was then and there has been some
xenophobia then but then they were
integrated and blended in and nobody's
talking about the East then we had a
huge Turkish minority with different
integration issues but I would say still
integration happened more or less quite
well when you go now to certain areas in
Berlin you see there's a lot of Arab
emigration coming on not only Syria but
many Lebanese people and others
different immigration different issues
education for instance they've been
their society values differ from from
the ones lived here to a certain extent
young boys are not willing to listen to
female primary school teachers for
instance all this kind of thing has to
has to be addressed to avoid failures in
education and those issues perhaps not
being addressed now we can see there is
a left-wing political establishment in
Germany as pegida suggests not entirely
its beginning look at Noah : for the for
the mayor there has no : for listeners
units there's a gentrified area and
there's a quite a poor heavily
concentrated immigrant area and the
school performance has been abysmal and
the level of discipline the level of an
young young boys hustling than female
teachers it's it and the mayor has taken
control of this and he set up special
programs it's going to take time but
slowly it's beginning to work but this
is going to take this is about
adaptation and it really needs the
support of parents as well
not only the teachers and the
politicians but the parents must feel
involved in this integration to give the
next generation a stake into society
it's so complicated also to use the
potential of the original background
culture for some of my mother's teacher
most teachers she died four years ago
she was absolutely shocked when she she
remarked that there's really boys who
are disregarding female teachers she
couldn't understand that was not
possible as a teacher coming from Turkey
so but we were always thinking all those
people are all Muslims we are all
somehow together and they we do the same
things no there are big differences and
but what we lost in the last decade I
will say in the last 10-15 years we lost
this power of secularized Muslim
societies we can now observe it also in
Turkey and this is this is the real
danger then because this leads real to a
polarization between the two volts this
Western European world and the others
you know the Muslim world somehow
looking for other values and or
slaughtering each other and I don't know
what but in the end and we have to avoid
this I think it's deploring to say well
I think this is the easiest way if we
look at your martyr of today's
discussion where pegida might have a
chance to get to go Europe is in this
anti Islamic mood they are feeding and
then my mind very easily in in the
current situation they might very easily
find allies everywhere in Europe and
this the question that is what does
piggy to have to do with with other
similar European movements again I'm
using that word like new capo from
Nacional in France other similarities is
their common ground or is Paquita
something very specifically German I
want it I'll answer very briefly I mean
they're tapping they're tapping into
what Sofia was saying the idea that this
Islam out there this is the other nurse
this is the this is our enemy to the
so-called judeo-christian culture of
Europe it's not part of our values and
what has to be broken down is - is this
myth that's it's homogeneous and what
was hope it's builds up on this for the
Chancellor and the Muslim communities in
the Jewish communities held our man on a
few weeks ago in the in the centre of
Berlin if this can be not just continued
because this is only symbolic but what
you need is what you have to break down
is the stereotype or all Muslims are the
same and involve in open discussions
that the other the other side of Islam
in Europe this is very very important
and somehow the voice hasn't come
through yet exactly cannot expect
ministers of interiors and Follies
comment making commentaries for Quran
and things like that this is a question
a cultural question and is also the
question why it's not possible to create
a culture picture of of Muslim societies
of Islam today which is more forceful
and terrorist attacks there's a big
question as a challenge you know well
that's the question well whether there
are similarities that biggie could build
on in relation to other right wing or
right populist parties in Europe not too
many because I still think Peggy dia is
a regional phenomenon up to now
but if they dwell on this anti-islamist
strain then might get somewhere and and
again and then this Euroskeptic element
as well i think these two are the ones
where they would find links to four
nacional links to youtube links to
dennis right-wing but you mustn't
underestimate the whole role of the
social media and the internet it's just
so easy now to spread the word it's so
these internet sites are very
sophisticated they're very very
expensively made there's money behind
these organizations I would even blame
ourselves to a certain extent to have
taken part in spreading the word of
pegida because media and Germany is very
on the alert when it comes to right-wing
movement and we are still very attentive
looking at everything and they choose a
very nice time for starting their
demonstration movement shortly before
Christmas
no not many other issues around so
everybody jumped on this ironic that the
media has given them so much prominence
top of the news agenda for weeks on end
really despite the fact and I'd like to
invite you to explain this for our
viewers that the pegida have been
describing the media have been
describing the press and the journalists
as the lugan press and that's the
terminology perhaps you could explain
that they might seem masochistic element
media people do but I think it's like I
said we we are always alarmed when
there's a right-wing movement coming up
because obviously the relations to
German history are so obvious and and so
they get a lot of attention and then it
was just good luck for them because know
many other issues were around at that
time but also on a coincided with the
bombing of the terrorist attacks in
Paris
so everything was conflated no
differentiation is Paquita got to do
with Paris they say it's just happening
at the same time but it's a coincidence
Peter but also it's oh it's it's the I
were just the Islam word and so oh those
those these were Islamic young people I
mean it did it feeds into this little
they exploited this the the Monday after
the bombings in the killings in in Paris
the the demonstrators which were very
hypocritical I was saying oh you know
this is this is terrible but what
happened in Paris but they twisted in
such a way you see and they said this we
will well right this is what's going to
happen know that this this surge of this
radical Islam so the manipulators
manipulators it as as best as they could
I don't know how how successful they are
going to be but this is this is a huge
problem and it's not confined Germany
was the last to come on board on this
sort of Islamophobia well I mean we have
also sometimes to listen a little bit
for example the spokeswoman of this pity
God said
the alarming point was the street fights
in summer we had street fights and I
think in Hamburg it was between Kurdish
groups and Salafists
yeah and this I can understand I must
say because I grew up in this country
and now how sensitive Germans are for
this sense of order you know all what is
happening outside you can do what you
want in a home but if you go on the
street again in the table I feel
responsible for so some people in there
is around because in Hamburg Kurds are
fighting with some Islamists and so on
they don't want it
I say if you want to fight go out and do
it outside you know it's not here so
this is this is the sense of again
bringing home and a nation on the plate
from on this issue because everyone will
agree no one wants fight on the street
so this is a very very big question and
it shows how important all the security
in this issue is that we are really
alarmed and we can we can really observe
what's happening and this groups and
even if they are small if we can control
it because if things like this spread
out all over the country will be very
very dangerous to stop populistic so if
you see this if this is this is a very
tricky situation times what you're
explaining let the public space before
the public the good public but if you
have your problems keep them at home or
go somewhere else but now it's out in
the public and there is the the not the
takeover of the public but the public
space is changing in Germany and that's
that's a very interesting phenomenon
it's maybe it's part of the
normalization it's not a bad thing but
but it's there's this part of the public
sphere which has changed over the past
couple of days I think the vast majority
of immigrants here are like the Roman we
have the same feeling you know it's very
good that there is not five like another
countries here we are in calm
it's not like in Paris it's not like in
the bondo people people if some Turkish
people in Noah come they think the first
thing they do is to move to piglets
that's another point yeah and I think
that recurs again to this field
that that you are more mobile in this
society because it's more leveled than
in other countries but then you have the
negative effects that people are getting
alarmed or fears are springing up on
everything else and in general I would
say that that's very generalizing but if
you if it comes to globalization or
modern world and to how our cities
change under this shape of the global
economy then I think the Germans are
more on the fear side not on the
optimistic side another difference to
the UK where people always think well
even if we get out of Europe we can find
our way in the globalized world we
Germans don't think we can do this
German word angst so interesting you
talk about you talk about the United
Kingdom there I was reading earlier this
week the the British journalist Timothy
Garton ash and he was saying look
Britain is a very sort of multicultural
society where especially in a city like
London people are rubbing up against
each other all the time they're pretty
accepting about each other but we need
to make progress he said and I waited I
read the whole article I'm who I'm
waiting for the his explanation of how
he believes we can make progress and he
basically said we have to sit in in
public space we have to give signals to
each other that there is no us and them
but in doing so what he said was that
there still is in very large measure and
us and them and our discussion today
reveals to me that in Germany there
still is a big us and them around Islam
that's my fear my feeling I don't know
if this is a real question for that is
of course kind of polarization like this
but the questions is it really involving
the whole society depends on where you
live I mean what strikes what strikes
visitors to Germany is that it's it's
very white frankly and that's the first
thing and secondly there is it's not
just Islam is the most demonstrative
problem at least in the public discourse
now but it's not easy you know coming
from Africa but
Asian I mean the Chinese community in
the Vietnamese communities are finding
their way here more and more pretend the
Indians were Indian engineers were
invited here they got a very very cold
reception and they've gone back to India
in fact they've gone off to sell Silicon
Valley so deep down there is Germany's
not unique just a fear of the other the
other news the fear of the fear of the
foreigner whether you're in a
traditional Hasidic Jew in in Antwerp
are different dress there's the and
there is an instinctive reaction that
and the other oness were not comfortable
with the of other nests and this is a
European phenomenon this is a post this
is a result of the second world war in
many ways I mean the Jewish community
was entirely almost entirely killed and
the we had to rebuild the economies
Germany and other countries brought in
lots of guests of gastro biter guest
workers do you think they were
integrated no the other nurse let them
stay away let me keep the distance in
our integrated and not as much as they
should be after three or four
generations frankly and I've discussed
this with the civil service with the
hospitals with with em but the
professions are only very very slowly
opening up to the third and fourth
generation I don't know if you would
agree that you tell that story in two
different ways there's a there's a
positive take and there's a negative
take I think pretty much here we're
getting quite close to the end of the
program I'm afraid I would just like to
ask the general question some people
have come out this week and said that
they believe that the pegida is a flush
in the pan that it's going to sort of
it's going to disappear in the next
couple of weeks as though it had never
been there others are saying that this
is no this is the start of something
much bigger and we will look back in a
few years time and see this as a sort of
a resurgence of difficult sentence up
here but the feelings will stay I will
say things are getting more volatile Pig
idiom might go but others might easily
more easily come back
it may implode but we have to see what
happens to the other movement more
sophisticated party the alternative for
Deutschland okay we're going to keep a
closer look on it Judy Johannes Schaffer
thank you very very much for your views
today I hope we've given you some food
for thought at home if so do come back
for the next week's edition of Korea fan
out bye-bye from Berlin and Trust
you